allez on va passer au dossier du jour on
va évoquer cet énorme scandale autour
des crèches demain et vendredi deux
livres d'enquête vont paraître ils vont
nous alerter très gravement sur les
crèches privées qui serait comparable je
cite à des usines à bébés couches non
changé alimentation pas ha niveau manque
de personnel maltraitance plusieurs
témoignages sont à peine croyable on a
avec nous Julia Fallon Julie Fallon qui
sera avec nous dans un instant encien
responsable d'une crèche privée qui a
vécu des choses insupportables elle sera
là dans quelques minutes vous allez voir
ce qu'elle va nous raconter c'est
complètement fou et juste après patrick
Montel sera avec nous ça je l'attends
avec impatience parce que ça ça va
secouer sec je vous le dis il est il est
énervé mon Patrick et et Dieu sait que
j'adore ce qu'il fait moi c'est c'est
voilà je l'aime j' une petit un petit
truc à lui proposer allez c'est
parti il y a quelques mois un rapport
sur la maltraitance dans les crèches
avait fait l'effet d'une bombe la
directrice a me dit qu'il s'est fait
griffer mais me dit il est défiguré et
cette semaine ce sont deux livres choc
qui dénoncent à leur tour des pratiques
douteuses dans ses établissements qui
chercheraient avant tout la rentabilité
ce système là ne met plus en avant
l'intérêt ant d'abord en avant l'intérêt
de l'entreprise manque de personnel
repas insuffisant enfants trop nombreux
les éléments pointés du doigt par des
témoignages de parents sont diviver et
font souvent froid dans le dosun mère
qui nous raconte qu'elle avait mis une
marque sur ses couche pour être sûr que
la couche était changée elle récupéré la
même le soir une situation qui inquiète
désormais la ministre de la Solidarité
et des familles Aurore berger alors
maltraitance dans les crèches nos
enfants sont-il en
danger merci Julie d'être là elle est
déjà venu nous voir c'était très
intéressant d'ailleurs vous étiez ven
voir Julie alors vous êtes ancienne
responsable d'une crèche privée tout à
fait c'est il y a eu petit souci oui on
se RA exactement comment ça va vous déjà
je me reconstruis petit à petit ah c'est
ça ça va mieux oui oui oui je sais que
vous aviez un petit moral à l'époque bah
oui parce que parce que ce genre de
situation des trucs quand même pas mal
je sais moi et puis puis tout pour
travailler là maintenant ou pas du tout
je crée un organisme de formation dans
tout ce qui est prévention et sécurité
d'accord très bien et ben si vous
pouviez nous sécuriser Gil verd ça nous
arr alors pas forcément cette sécurité
là mais vous avez bien raison bon alors
on voit il y a de livres qui sortent sur
les crèches vous nous aviez alerté à
l'époque là comment ça se passe dans les
crèches alors moi j'y suis plus du coup
hein parce que depuis depuis cette
histoire en fait moi j'ai perdu j'ai
perdu ma société on va rappeler
l'histoire moi j'ai découvert en août
2021 que deux de mes salariés
commettaient des actes de violence sur
enfant plutôt que juste les licenciés et
éventuellement qu'elle soit réembauché
et qu'elle recommence ailleurs j'ai
préféré les dénoncer à la police
nationale donc il y a eu tout un procès
et le résultat c'est que bah moi j'en ai
perdu en fait mon entreprise
étant petite indépendante voilà les gros
groupes il peut leur
arriver des histoires pareilles ils vont
pas fermer une crèche municipale si si
ça arrive aussi chez eux on fera pas
fermer une crèche municipale les petit
oui est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire ce
qui se passe parce qu'il y a on dit que
il y a des insultes sur les enfants déjà
alors il y a de la violence physique il
y a de la violence verbale euh en ce qui
me concerne en fait les les les deux
salariés traitent les enfants de Sal
[__] de connard de couillon ah oui
c'était assez assez violent mais si vous
forcez un enfant à manger c'est déjà de
la violence sû ou vous on vous force pas
à manger non on pas
besoin ça va non mais si vous n'aimez
pas ou
ou bah voilà forcer un enfant oui il
faut qu'il goûte de tout mais s'il a pas
envie bah c'est déjà de la violence ça
bien sûr ça a des conséquences sur les
enfants qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'il y
a d'autre parce que on on on dit voilà
qu'il y a des agissements qui vont qui
qui vont qui vont sortir dans ce livre
là qui sont complètement fou on parle de
maltraitant donc vous dit insulte donc
alimentation aussi pas au niveau alors
je alors moi ça n'a jamais été le cas
j'ai toujours commander tout ce qu'il
fallait pour par rapport au nombre
d'enfants maintenant oui il y a des il y
a des les gros groupes qui pour faire
des économies ne commandent pas le
nombre de repas nécessaires par rapport
au nombre d'enfants par jour et du coup
bah il y a pas la bonne quantité de
repas donc il y a des des repas qui sont
on a entendu qu'il y avait des problèmes
de surbooking c'est-à-dire que il y
avait pas suffisamment de place pour le
nombre personnel il y a il y a trop
d'enfants par rapport aux structures il
y a il y a pas assez de repas enfin
voilà on tire en fait de de chaque côté
alors là on en parle beaucoup après je
veux pas non plus alarmer trop les les
parents c'est pas partout c'est surtout
surtout dans les crèches privées ou pas
non parce que moi une de mes salariés
faisait commettait ses actes de violence
dans une crèche municipale la crèche
municipale n'a rien fait bah elle a été
licenciée elle m'a envoyé son CV je l'ai
en on a l'impression qu'il y a de plus
en plus de cas c'est de plus en plus
inquiétant pour les parents Gill mais
oui on entend des témoignages
incroyables genre dans les crèches on
oublie de donner à boire aux enfants ou
on s'en aperçoit le soir il y a des pars
de repas sur lesqueles on rogne en
permanence c'est c'est parce qu'on veut
gagner de l'argent ou parce que le
personnel est nul et pas formé il va y
avoir toutes les situations il y en a
c'est pour gagner de l'argent mais
gagner de l'argent sur un verre d'eau
gagner d'argent sur des couches à la
rigueur mais sur un verre d'eau non vous
regardez sur les
couches je sais
pas sur la propreté merci j merci non
mais mais voilà sur sur ce genre de
situation non après il faut bien
comprendre que dans certaines
situations vous en tant que parents si
vous avez CIN enfants à gérer dans la
journée vous y arrivez pas bah là
certaines salariées ont 5 6 7 SEP
enfants à gérer toutes seul et ben quand
un enfant pleure parce qu'il a faim bah
c'est un peu à la chaîne en fait ouais
donc il faut on manque vraiment de
personnel benaimus oui pour les pour les
crèches privées Gilles évoquait
éventuellement la course au rendement
mais effectivement il y a eu un rapport
qui a été accablant de l'Inspection
générale des affaires sociales en avril
dernier qui est vraiment
ou non mais absolument desl TER vraiment
c'est c'est un rapport qui qui parle de
course au rendement de système
déshumanisés qui confine à la
maltraitance et qui par ailleurs
explique que en fait il y a 80000 places
de dans les crèches privées mais que
comme il y a un chiffre d'affaires qui
est estimé entre 1 milliard et 1
milliard 4 pour les pour les les crèches
privées ben en fait on essaie de faire
toujours plus toujours plus toujours
plus pour gagner toujours plus au
détriment des enfants donc effectivement
s'il faut leur donner un petit pot pour
deux au lieu de un petit pot pour chacun
on fera un petit pot pour deux et cetera
et cetera et ça commence là la
maltraitance c'est ça c'est ça alors moi
je j'ai jamais réussi à être rentable en
8 ans donc jamais réussi à être rentable
non jamais en 8 ans en 8 ans non mon
compable vous parce
que
Ch mon personnel j'avais plus de
personnel que prévu elles étaient trois
pour 10 enfants ah ouaisou parce qu'on a
entendu aujourd'hui un certain nombre de
directeurs de crèche privée dire que
c'était profitable qui pouvait faire du
business avec des c pas trouvé la
bonne PASC deour moi j'ai une question a
a poser peut-être que il faudrait la
poser à la ministre des Solidarités où
en est-on le gouvernement s'était engagé
à créer 200000 places de crèche d'ici
2030 on est déjà en 2023 bientôt 2024
est-ce que ça a commencé parce qu' a un
problème
de ont déjà donné 10
ici est-ce que ça a commencé il y en a
il y en a que la moitié mais en fait oui
ils ouvrent il il donnent la possibilité
aux gens d'ouvrir mais après on n pas
les moyens derrière a pas personnel
derrière PL pas
il est pas il est pas attrayant les les
les salariés sont payés au SMIC c'est
pas valorisé allez passer toute une
journée avec 10 20 30 enfants qui jouent
dans une même pièce ça fait du bruit ça
fait du bruit enfin fait on a quand même
un problème en France avec le fait qu'il
y a de plus en plus de métiers qui
apparemment ne sont pas attrayants c'est
probablement que ces métiers ne sont pas
assez
payéou ENF voilà on a ces problèmes là
dans les milieux de la restauration le
constat est le même apparemment dans
pour la petite enfance mais aussi pour
le grand âge oui donc ça fait quand même
beaucoup de métier en
fait solarité P la grande inquiétude
c'est quand on maltraite un enfant un
petit enfant il ne parle pas c'est ça
l'angoisse des parents comment faire
comment faire quand on est parent qu'on
a peut-être un doute comment arriver
l'enfant à exprimer qu'il est maltraité
qu'il mange pas bien qu sont meilleur en
question qu'on av alors généralement il
y a un changement de comportement il
peut y avoir voilà une nuit qui devient
des nuits qui deviennent difficiles un
enfant qui va arrêter de manger qui va
changer d'attitude quand on l'amène à la
crèche pourquoi il veut pas venir à la
crèche euh c'est c'est c'est ces petits
ces petites choses là qui peuvent
alarmer les les les familles et il faut
que les familles en fait si si elles
constatent quelque chose ou ou si même
une parole ne leur convient pas qu'elle
qu'ell le disent qu'elles aillent voir
la direction ou le personnel ou même
directement euh dénonciation police
nationale bien alors on attend mais il
faut pas le laisser faire en fait on
attend ces ces livres d'enquête qui vont
paraître et qui vont on va bien sûr en
reparler dans cette émission merci Julie
d'avoir été avec nousz quand vous voulez
c'est toujours un plaisir merci merci